whether it's for project collaboration
finding a mentor or even potential
employers hackathons are a great place
to make connections that could pay
dividends in the future that is why this
November we are organized in a hackathon
on microbiome in health and wellness to
provide students with a platform to
Showcase their Innovative mindset of
problem solving in this hackathon each
student will have the opportunity to
develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic form a team with at
least two other students and compete
against others for mentorship support
from well-established companies and
long-term interest from the business
Community the applications of hackathon
are in the fields of obesity and
position nutrition Innovation and beauty
products and pregnancy
so now you might be wondering if I
register for the hackathon will I get
any resources to help me develop a
project and the answer is yes
once you register for the hackathon you
will have access to research and
computational infrastructure through the
T bioinfo platform a balance Matrix
platform that combines statistical
analysis modules into pipelines to deal
with heterogeneous Big Data as a part of
the hackathon you will also receive
access to premium license to the omics
project training that has been completed
by over 24 000 participants from 187
countries in over 300 workshops and as a
part of this we'll have access to online
coursework support and mental guidance
you will also receive access to
practical example projects and curated
project data sets and case studies on
microbiome based clinical research
studies finally you will also have
access to a three week full of expert
workshops and Mentor guidance week one
Workshop will be on microbiome business
and the topics covered include
microbiome health and wellness or mix
and microbiome Technologies
bioinformatics for health and wellness
and recommendation systems week 2
Workshop is on biotechnology and the
topics covered include gut microbiome
health and diet skin microbiome Beauty
comfort and aging vaginal microbiome
pregnancy and femtech
week 3 will be on computer science and
the topics covered include
infrastructure for computational
analysis tools methods and algorithms
machine learning recommendation system
data visualization and user experience
after the completion of the training
workshops you are required to develop a
minimum viable product on one of the
hackathon topics and this will be
presented at the main event which will
be conducted from November 23rd to
November 28th
after participation students will also
receive the opportunity to get
certification and recognition and if
selected students can also win exciting
cash prizes and finding opportunities
so the hackathon we are joined by a wide
network of scientists investors and
experts including this Liliana not back
a Serial entrepreneur and investor in
high-tech and biotech companies with a
demonstrated history of building several
companies from inception to IPO
if you wish to participate in hackathon
here are some of the important dates
that you need to keep in mind the
registration commenced on September 30th
and it is still ongoing the
registrations will close on October 31st
the hackathon training program will
commence on November 1st and the main
hackathon event will be conducted from
November 23rd to November 28th
now to get all the details that I've
explained and to get regular updates
about our upcoming workshop and speakers
you can simply visit the main hackathon
page here and click on the link
register for the microbiome in health
and wellness hackathon button
and once you click on this a form will
pop up and here you'll be simply asked
to enter some of your details such as
your name email ID phone number country
City company Department name of the team
members and you can just fill it out and
you can get all the details that have
been explained here now coming to the
registration cost
if you are participating as an
individual student the registration cost
is dollar 100 and if you are
participating as a group of students the
cost will be drawn to 300 and if you are
a student of one of our partner
universities you can Avail 65 percentage
discount and register just for dollar
hundred to see if your University
belongs to a partnership program you can
simply visit the partnership program
page link that is provided here
and for the individual student payment
and group of students and partnership
University participants each category of
payment gateways have been listed you
can simply click on this and enter the
details that are asked and complete your
registration and that's it for the
registration details with that I would
like to urge all the students to make
most out of such wonderful opportunity
and participate in this exciting habit